have you had people come in and say I
want the gun that's in this game yeah
and you're crazy
yup kids that are just turning 21
they're like they're like they're like
hey what is what's that on the wall on
my OS a Chris vector and it's a sweet
decked out looking a little submachine
gun thing it's not actual machine gun
it's a carbine and semi automatic
because we're not getting a yeah there
you go Chris vector yeah and and it's
like oh yeah man I used to I used to run
that thing and Call of Duty managed to
run that thing and wanted warfare to all
types of yeah or just like I mean I had
a dude come in there didn't know
anything about guns you know rich guy
you know he came up in a Porsche
he was like I'm looking for the revolver
that Dirty Harry used Wow
in in then Dirty Harry I'm like alright
like the one like you know Clint
Eastwood use and he's like yeah that's
the one am i alright so Smith & Wesson
Model 29 and I hand it to him but we
actually had one they still make him a
commercial production there you go 44
Magnum and he was like yeah I'll take it
didn't wanna know anything about the gun
just wanted it because it was in Dirty
Harry yeah that's it so it's just
amazing to me that someone sees it in a
video game or something like oh now I
got to have this yeah they just want
especially if it's a game for my grand
theft auto key driving around with that
yeah yeah on your lap man just shooting
[ __ ] yeah that's just how it if
do you huh
have you ever sold a gun that was used
in a crime or murder I wouldn't know we
do get we do get like police trade in
guns and it's not unheard of for police
departments to have to pick up guns this
all mean all around the country they you
know they pick up guns and crimes and
then they that pretty much clear the
crime out but they still have the
firearm with the confiscated off
somebody and then they'll be sell at the
gun stores and the gun stores are
selling used for cheap price it's really
really popular so there's plenty of guns
out there that have I'm sure they have
some bodies on them like I got an old I
got an old SKS right so it I've seen it
in uh I think in Call of Duty an SKS I
think so I don't know man it's it was it
was a rifle used in the Vietnam War Lada
the one I have was manufactured in uh in
China but it's a it's a cool rifle and
yeah yeah and it's an awesome rifle it's
a first gun I ever bought man when I
turned 18 I bought that thing and and
the one I got was a was a Vietnam bring
back so some veteran was in Vietnam
probably smoked
some Vietnamese dude had an SKS and then
took it home when he came back from the
war and so who knows what that rifle is
seen you know yeah and I mean the one I
got was made in 1953 so it's a it's
definitely seen something you know have
some killing years but it's older than
my pops oh yeah man I mean that thing
was probably like you know it really
early stage of Vietnam War you know and
they were used fight I mean there's an
originally a Russian gun the gun was it
was invented by a Russian inventor
siminoff but then you know how the
Russians are you know their communist
Union so all of their designs after they
kind of were like declared antiquated
they kind of just spread it around the
you know the the Socialist United world
and so China pretty much got their
manufacturing rights to make these and
the Chinese love them and they made them
in the millions there's millions of
these things around the world right now
you have pick you have pictures of
African tribes yeah you see a lot of
those oh yeah extended you know earlobes
the whole thing and they don't they're
not even wearing western clothing and
they have an old Chinese SKS over there
over their shoulder that's that's their
gun isn't it interesting like so much of
that uh of the firearms trade that goes
on it's unbelievable I mean whatever you
think is going on commercially in the US
just think under the table
internationally yeah insane I mean you
have countries that you would even
expect like HK in Germany massive
firearms producer they sell they sold I
mean I think like 20,000 g3 rifles to
Saudi Arabia and then all of a sudden
they have they found a bunch of these
rifles it went in the hands of Isis
yes Syria or they found them in and
these militia groups you know al-nusrah
in Syria and they have all these g3
rifles that were just sent to Saudi
Arabia so there's there's actually like
a lot of international organizations
that kind of track where these where
these things show up I mean those
pictures of like the conflict in Syria
the civil war where they're driving a
Panzer 4 from World War 2 a German tank
you know it's like where the [ __ ] did
they get that [ __ ] that thing weighs 25
tons where the [ __ ] did they get that
yeah they're [ __ ] Isis driving over
Ford Tauruses as well oh yeah but I'm
just saying there's such a there's such
like a secondary market that well it's
so funny like how on the surface would
be like you know no guns no guns no guns
and then if you go and look at
how America makes money one of the ways
is through selling firearms to different
countries it's crazy firearms it's a
fraction of it if you think about the
military-industrial complex we're
talking weapon systems
I mean fighter jets missiles things that
one single f-35 right lightning to the
pretty much our newest fifth-generation
multi-role jet I mean they're worth
[ __ ] billions of dollars it's just
the whole program itself and and they're
sent then they're sold to all these
countries in NATO and I mean all these
weapons systems just end up in the hands
of all types of people it's it's the
weapons trade not just small arms not
just riding guns and rice so up or to
even everything-everything
intercontinental ballistic missiles old
submarines ships everything everything
these the defense industry
internationally and even under the table
is [ __ ] monument evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one